I changed my answer I would marry Andy
okay Oh while listening to Christina
Aguilera and having sex with you yeah
fair enough right
why Mariah because we made a movie with
her and she seemed really nice I feel
like she wouldn't forgive me okay
she's she's things like the nicer one no
no I want to have sex to both of them
just one I'm going I'm going Christina
wait am I having sex with you or Emma
having sex with you all of us
okay then Adele Adele both would be an
honor
yeah yeah I would take I think that's a
that's a little bit of a bucket list to
work your way into one of those some
definitely both definitely both Emily
both final answer both oh I know you
know what I would give to be able to hit
the high note I don't either that's okay
that's like your iShare negative yeah
these are these are all positive have
that vocal range I could stop doing
comedy yeah but he didn't say you can
just hit it in any other circumstance
you're just hitting that day when you
want to ask you yeah we go the eggs cuz
they want like my face and hair on fire
that's a good choice yeah that makes
sense
I don't know but the the fireworks are
very empowering right the fireworks like
that honor empowering for her
whipped cream we are I mean what's fun
yeah and just it'll smell less tastier
it's of just a general health concern
unless I was going to Korean barbecue
and that I might just prefer to put that
put two lip up be like I'm just gonna
pay for some soju and then take off
Brittany was pretty fine in that video
though this isn't about either lady this
is just about the set are they there are
they there yeah cuz at some point
everyone's gonna pair off you know they
mean you're gonna be like and I'm
married to a giant teddy bear or you're
like some hot backup dancer or Taylor
Swift I probably go over better you're
talking about flirting too not just
talking so I give you an example keep of
you flirting with taylor swift lyrics
how are we out of the woods yet are we
out of the woods you know we out of the
woods you know yeah a little that made
me want to go jay-z and Beyonce I feel
like Calvin Harris and Taylor would look
like harder because they're younger and
I and I feel like I'd rather see because
I assume I'm there for everything so
wait yeah you think they're gonna have
sex in front of you yeah I'm a third
wheel